Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
this video,
start your free trial and now we're to
link in the description below
in the short video essay.
I want to explore a contradiction I
noticed when we watching two excellent
film centered around American slavery,
12 years a slave and Django unchained,
12 years a slave of course tells the
true story of Solomon Northup Free New
Yorker,
who is abducted and sold into slavery
for 12 years before is fried.
Now.
Twelve years of slave is a heavy drama
that carries the full weight of the
horror of slavery.
Django unchained,
however,
is in many ways the total opposite.
I can't see fucking shit outage.
We ready or what?
Oh,
hold on.
I'm not going with my whole Django
definitely has moments where the horrors
of slavery are conveyed through brutal
and difficult scenes.
Yet it is also a term Tino film
featuring violence as spectacle and a
big dose of comedy.
I said Ms Dot Lowe,
goodbye,
but
this created as is not uncommon with
county,
no controversy.
Media scholar,
Glenda Carpio notes that the discourse
of race and slavery in America has
mostly gravitated towards steep
seriousness and sensitivity.
Django unchained,
therefore raise the question if certain
film genres such as Komani are
inherently inadequate for capturing the
history of slavery,
can turn and be forgiven for not
adhering to historical accuracy,
but it's not be forgiven for striking
the quote unquote wrong tone,
addressing such a sensitive subject,
Michelle,
to load the this discussion as well of
historical authenticity instead of
historical accuracy as he argues is not
only the your executive dudes over stoke
or representation,
but also the context of its consumption
that's determines its meaning.
Critics of Django this argued that its
approach of humor and filing spectacle
hurts and trivializes not only the
memory of slavery,
but also institutional racism that
fullerton under Jim Crow and the
discussion about racism and race that is
prevalent in American society today.
I would argue though that this is
untrue,
the different tonal style stanton,
new uses in Jenga and change each shift
to own function.
In my analysis of inglorious bastards,
I discussed how Terentino's violence,
both s entertaining spectacle and as
something brutal and horrific as,
for example,
white crackers pointed out,
he does the same in Django and chains to
violence against black slaves,
his crew,
horrific and hard to watch.
Just as in 12 years a slave.
It drives home the horrible and gruesome
history of slavery.
Terentino's reserves is useful.
Filings as spectacle and fun for the
slave holders and other characters who
represent the ideology of racism and
slavery.
No,
I find Terentino's use a few more of the
most interesting tonal aspect of the
film.
Well,
it's Terentino's I think realizes is
that humor does not affect trivialize
slavery,
birth and it has the capacity to
ridicule and it's been a ride.
I log that,
uphold slavery,
taking away its power and providing a
form of Catharsis.
My name is Dr King Schults.
This is my triangle.
These our horses totally fits.
This power of comedy is also recognized
by a comedian such as key and peele and
Dave Chappelle who also ridicule and
make fun of the ideology of slavery.
Not to trivialize it,
but to take away its power.
Examples of this are seen in Django
unchained where supposedly terrifying
clan rate is juxtaposed with ridiculous
discussion about being unable to see two
white bags.
Fuck all y'all.
Hold on.
Going on.
No,
I watched my wife work.
Oh,
day.
Get 30 bags together for you.
Ungrateful Sons of bitches and all.
I've been here to criticize,
criticize,
criticize.
Don't ask me for nothing
or key and peele skits were two slaves.
Feel rejected when they are not being
bought during the slave auction.
It's all chins over.
It ain't over.
It's not over.
I'm strong y'all.
I'm very shy.
I can sleep in a bucket.
I'm fast.
I got stamina.
I don't look at.
I know magic.
My worst quality is that I'm a
perfectionist.
I haven't mentioned this.
Dust Silent.
I am agreeable to a fault.
There was also a striking similarity
between the scene where Django shoots,
slave master,
slave,
and Dave Chappelle skit where he travels
back in time to confront a slave owner.
He had made lanes and even get new shoes
on deck.
I could never go out like that.
So you really free.
Yes,
that's true.
He didn't pull it out.
A whip.
Nice whip.
There's there's a pistol.
Reach Foolish Guy,
hungry.
No,
that's Glenda Carpio.
Rq spoke,
Chappelle and Tino use their mediums to
affect scenes of retribution against
slavery.
Using humor to boats sharpened the edge
if that ritual and to highlight the
artificiality of representations in my
few boats.
Twelve years of slave and Django and are
excellent films.
Birth Django unchained should not be
criticized for its use of humor around
sensitive subjects to slavery and race.
To do so would be for guests to healing
qualities that comedy can have.
All
right,
thank you all for watching.
So due to a busy month,
I wanted to do a slightly shorter video
essay about power that's company can
have in discussing difficult subjects,
something that seems to be forgotten
more and more these days.
Furthermore,
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
If any of you want to build your own
website in the new year to feature your
art videos,
photography,
writing,
or anything else,
squarespace is the best way to do it.
It's features beautiful,
elegant,
and simple to use.
Templates anyone can use to create an
amazing website without needing the
ability to coat you can also build your
complete website before committing to
anything to the free trial.
Use the link in the description below
together with promo codes storytellers
to get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Finally,
a very happy new year to everyone and we
will see you in 2018.